[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the five most powerful witches and
wizards that came from Hufflepuff house
at Hogwarts in two of my older videos I
showed you my top five lists for
Gryffindor and Slytherin and I've been
seeing a lot of requests for Hufflepuff
and Ravenclaw so here we go
Eiffel puff is best introduced in
assorting Hatsune words you might belong
in half a puff where they are just and
loyal those patient hufflepuffs are true
and unafraid of toil each of the four
houses are known for lots of different
things but usually there is one
particular aspect that sticks out where
Krishna is known for its brief alumni
and Slytherin is known for its
cultivation of dark witches and wizards
hufflepuff is known for producing the
fewest number of dark witches and
wizards
hufflepuffs are hardworking wholesome
trustworthy loyal and have an impeccably
strong work ethic but Hufflepuff gets a
bit of a hard time from sun and is
publicly criticized as being neither
particularly exceptional or clever but
this is far from the truth as Hufflepuff
has produced some of the most impressive
witches and wizards to date now if you
know how courts history which you should
and you will know that hogwarts had four
founders Rowena Ravenclaw Salazar
Slytherin alcohol puff and Godric
Gryffindor the four founders enchanted
her hats the sorting yet a hat that
would allocate students to each of the
houses after the student places the hat
on their head begins to analyze their
mind and places them in the house based
on her closely resemble one of the four
founders if the Hat senses great bravery
Gryffindor is the likely choice
ravenclaw valued intelligence I hope our
failure to hard work and so therein
valued aspirations for power with that
in mind let's take a look at five of the
hardest workers viola the most powerful
hufflepuffs
to have ever lived number five Cedric
Diggory Cedric Diggory was a British
pureblood wizard born in the year 1977
he began sitting in Hogwarts in the year
1989 two years before Harry Potter and
the tree
Cedric was a talented wizard and was
sorted into half a puff house in his
formative year Cedric had a reputation
of being a bit of a pretty boy but was
well-liked by the student body
eventually becoming prefect for
Hufflepuff house and captain of the half
above Quidditch team Cedric was popular
but he was not pompous or arrogant and
showed on numerous occasions that he was
a fair respectable man when Harry was
attacked by de Mendez in the Hufflepuff
versus Gryffindor Quidditch match
another puff one Cedric immediately
offered to replay the match when he
found out additionally when the whole
school was sporting Potter stinks
badgers and their 94-95 school year
dickery showed his sympathy to Harry hey
listen about the badges have asked them
not to wear them perhaps most notably
Cedric competed against Harry in the
Triwizard Tournament Ditka was the
talented representative powerful puff
and Harry for Gryffindor at the end of
the tournament
the two boys agreed to share the glory
of winning and grasps the Triwizard Cup
simultaneously unbeknownst to them the
cup had been turned into a port key and
the pair were transported to little
ankles in graveyard where Wormtail and
Voldemort awaited their arrival it was
here that Cedric was tragically killed
when Cedric died Dumbledore had many
kind words to say about Cedric we all
celebrate a boy who was kind and honest
and brave and true right to the very end
but Cedric was not only well-liked and a
good person he was also very magically
gifted Barty Crouch jr. discussed his
moody had this to say about Cedric by
the time he was your age he could turn a
whistle into a watch and have it seen at
the time as the Triwizard Tournament
progressed we saw many notable examples
of Cedric's talent as a wizard his
Transfiguration capabilities shone
through and he successfully transformed
a rock into a dog during the first task
of the tournament we gotta see his
charms work firsthand in a second task
of the tournament when he successfully
produced a bubblehead charm which
suggests that he achieved either and
exceeds expectations or a standing grade
in his owl exam Cedric even produced a
stunning spell strong enough to stand in
defeat acromantula which is a very
powerful creature in the end Cedric was
more
a popular guy at school he died a hero
number four Nymphadora Tonks Nymphadora
Tonks was a british half pot which the
daughter of muggle-born edward tanks and
pure blood which andromeda Tonks who was
a formal member of the house of black
Tonks most notable characteristic is
that she is a metamorph Magus metamorph
meg I are born with their amazing
ability to change their physical form at
will they possess the power to change
their entire physical parents but also
the ability to hone in on specific parts
of their appearance changing only those
things it was apparent that Nymphadora
was a metamorph Magus one day she was
born as she would constantly change her
hair color Tong's began at Hogwarts in
the in 1984 and was promptly sorted into
half of house this was interesting as
most students who had ties to the house
of black was sorted into Slytherin house
as Tonks was the daughter of Andromeda
who'd been ostracized for fraternizing
with the muggle-born she was rejected by
members of the black family in an
interesting turn of events
Tonks was eventually murdered by her
maternal aunts Bellatrix Lestrange while
at school tongues showed considerable
magical ability and even taught herself
to complicated Patronus charm in her
fourth year she also achieved high
enough grades to lay to pursue a career
as an aura which is no easy feat tongs
would also later join the order of the
Phoenix a secret society founded by
Dumbledore that fought for naught in the
Death Eaters over the years she
showcased exceptional capabilities in a
multitude of magical disciplines
including defense against the dark arts
charms Transfiguration flying potions
and more number three Pomona sprouts
Pomona sprout it was a British pureblood
witch and head of Hufflepuff house she
presided as head of the House for many
years and exemplified the traits of a
fourth house compassion tolerance and
fairness this is perfectly encapsulated
in the following quote from sprout I am
sure Dumbledore would have wanted the
school to remain open said professor
sprout I feel that if a single people
wants to come in the school to remain
open for that pupil those sprout is
relatively unassuming as a powerful
witch she should certainly not be
underestimated
sprout was an expert at herbology and
taught apology during the day but was
also extremely versed in many of their
magical disciplines her skill of
producing charms and love of herbology
enabled her produce all sorts of
herbology related charms such as the
fire making charm and severing charm
sprouts could also notably produce a
noncorporeal Petronius an extremely
difficult piece of magic that generally
signifies a talented witch or wizard
sprout also showcased her advanced
dueling capabilities on numerous
occasions fighting off Death Eaters in
the Battle of Hogwarts and even helping
McGonagall and Flitwick to chase Snape
out of Hogwarts number two Newt
Scamander we first get to meet Newt
Scamander in the fantastic beasts films
though there isn't easter egg in the
original films that points to his
existence mute is of course the famed
Magister ologist and the author of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
a book outlining the study of magical
creatures it is the most comprehensive
book on magical creatures in existence
and shortly after its release became a
Hogwarts staple newts masterpiece had
been an approved textbook at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry ever
since its publication and must take a
substantial amount of credit for
students consistently high results who
care of magical creatures examinations
newt of course amassed his level of
knowledge by travelling across the world
I have visited layers boroughs and nests
across the five continents observed the
curious habits of magical beasts in a
hundred countries witnessed their powers
gained their trust and on occasion
beaten them off with my travelling
cattle new to began attending Hogwarts
in the year 1908 and were sorted into
Hufflepuff house on the 1st of September
however this time at the school was
relatively short-lived as he was
expelled in 1913 in the year that Newt
was expelled his love interest liitle
estranged had been experimenting with
the javy a magical beasts resembling an
overgrown ferret her experiment to put
the lives of other students in jeopardy
a newt ended up taking the blame for
leaders actions
securing an expulsion for himself newts
professor at the time
Albus Dumbledore argued on his behalf
but ultimately did not hold enough power
to keep Newt at the school despite never
completing his formal education knew too
had gone to achieve some
and credible things and was partly
responsible for the eventual downfall of
Gellert Grindelwald in addition to his
knowledge in the care of magical
creatures which is a bit of a given newt
also exhibited extreme talent in other
areas of magic though he was not
necessarily a highly praised for his
abilities or outwardly confident while
at school newt became the favorite
student of Professor Albus Dumbledore
who was continually impressed with newt
and his magical capabilities this is
nothing to scoff at coming from Albus
Dumbledore who was arguably the most
powerful wizard to have ever lived newt
was able to successfully survive at
least two encounters with Gellert
Grindelwald even once holding him at bay
for a time by himself kuhn Dewald was
one of the most powerful dark wizards of
all time so this is a true testament to
the capabilities of newt newt skills
were even bigger Qing Lee noticed by
torkoal Travers Rudolf Spielman in
Arnolds Boozman a newt was offered the
position of aura this is a massive
statement and a true testament of news
capabilities given that he didn't even
have a complete education I should add
that I think that newt and his brother
Theseus are perhaps equally deserving of
this spot as Theseus was impressive in
his own right Theseus was exceptionally
talented and was both head of the ore
office and a war hero number one Helga
Hufflepuff we don't actually have a lot
of information on Helga but what we do
know is that the founders of Hogwarts
all four of them were immensely powerful
the Hogwarts founders a widely thought
to have possessed power that was
entirely and comparable to most
modern-day witches and wizards unlike
the other founders hufflepuff didn't
have much of an elitist mentality and
just wanted students to be educated
regardless of where they were sorted she
wasn't competitive I'll teach the lot
and treat them just the same she was a
round plump woman with brown and blue
eyes she would often sport a smile and
frequently donned brown or yellow dress
while we don't know much about Helga and
her feats of magical ability we do know
that she was exceptionally gifted at
charms not only did she helped the other
four founders enchanting the sorting hat
she was also particularly versed at
food-related charms and was known to
possess the ability to produce a
noncorporeal Patronus even though there
is a lack of information out there on
Helga it's hard not give her this spot
given that the four founders are widely
speculated to have possessed power and
comparable to most modern-day witches
and wizards and that's it for this video
I think there is some room for
rearranging some names here but I did my
best what do you guys think who were
your top 5 let me know down in the
comments section below until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]